antoine c'était une célébration à minima
ce matin racontez nous oui c'est une
impression très étrange très bizarre de
se retrouver sur la place rouge en plein
milieu de moscou dans une place rouge
complètement vide complètement déserte
1,9 mais alors qu'à 9 mai c'est une
c'est un endroit qui est complètement
plein à craquer sur le côté de la place
le long des murs du kremlin se trouve
normalement des gradins des tribunes qui
accueillent l'état-major de l'armée
russe des anciens combattants ou encore
des dignitaires et chefs d'état
étrangers comme par exemple qui aurait
dû se trouver là aujourd'hui le
président chinois xi jinping ou encore
le président français emmanuel mâcon
mais voilà coronavirus oblige
rien de tout ça cet anime l'admirent
poutine malgré tout était présent pour
déposer une gerbe sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu ce matin avant ensuite de
s'adresser à la nation je vous propose
d'écouter une partie de son intervention
ils ont combattu contre la mort pour la
vie et nous nous alignons sur leur
dignité
nous sommes réunis dans cet espoir dans
cet espoir dans ses aspirations
la responsabilité pour le présent et
pour l'avenir un nos savons et nous
avons cette assurance que nous sommes
invisibles invincible quand nous sommes
ensemble
bonne fête bon jour de la victoire 1
pour 1 la cérémonie officielle a ensuite
continué avec le passage en revue par va
dire poutine de la garde d'honneur du
régiment présidentiel avant ensuite
d'assister à la parade aérienne alors
pas de parade militaire classique au
sens où on l'entend normalement au sol
mais donc le volet aérien qui lui a été
maintenu avec 75 appareils qui ont
survolé la place rouge 20 hélicoptères
ainsi que 55 avions militaires en temps
normal s'en suit la marche du régiment
immortel des dizaines d'ennemis des
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
défilent le long des rues de la capitale
et ainsi que dans toutes les autres
villes de la russie est donc à la place
c'est en ligne via un site dédié vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure que la
population était invitée à livrer ces
témoignages c'est donc un 9 mai
exceptionnel à plus d'un titre qui sera
clos dans la soirée avec un grand feu
d'artifice coronavirus ou pas merci
beaucoup antal claironne depuis moscou